this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by upstart raycon
talk space and omax cryofreeze more on
that later let's get into the do
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here
doing it at studio night pants i'm ryan
sickler ryan sickler.com ryan sickler on
all social media night pants nation i
can't say thank you all enough you got
your shorts on you got your night pants
on y'all
comfortable door in the virus and i
appreciate all that you do
uh make sure you're subscribed to my
youtube channel
you're gonna be getting a video uh every
tuesday
over there audio on monday make sure you
subscribe to the patreon
i say it's five bucks a month i'm not
doing any tears
no merch and [ __ ] like that it's five
[ __ ] dollars it's 60
a year i listen i know that's a lot of
money to some people i know that's a
cell phone bill a utility bill i get it
but if you're looking for
more of the honeydew weekly it's two
shows now one on patreon
60 bucks a year you can opt out whenever
you want five bucks you're gonna get
four or five shows
look for a five week month maximize your
money you know what i'm saying then it's
a buck an episode and then you can
bounce out if you want to i hope you
don't
this would be some really good episodes
we thought somebody died
okay and i'm gonna keep saying it this
poor girl but two [ __ ]
all right um facebook fan page
uh all of it sign up the
honeydewpodcast.com that's where you can
get the merch everything is all there
for
you all right and you know i record here
at the santa monica music center
uh whether you live here in la or
wherever you live in the world thank you
by the way some of you have reached out
from canada
great britain uh to take your lessons
thank you very much
they offer online uh music lessons here
from locally trained los angeles
musicians go to santa monica music dot
com use the code honeydew
they're gonna waive the registration fee
and they're gonna give you a free lesson
when you sign up for a package that link
is also
on the honeydewpodcast.com now that all
that is out of the way
uh you know we do over here we highlight
the low lights these are the stories
behind the storytellers
today's storyteller returns and i've
been
super excited we've been trying to make
this happen for a minute there's a lot
of [ __ ] going on out there y'all ladies
and gentlemen
andrew santino is back
i want him to be clapping to the world
why aren't you clapping ash
he's clapping and laughing
i'm good man i'm good i'm good mid
pandemic i'm feeling okay
you feel like we're mid you feel like
we're yeah
midway through this is the halfway point
i think uh we'll be done by this uh next
march
that's my guess that's the groundhog's
guest that's a full year i think it's
full here
i think we're just through midway point
right now i mean you do look back but
we're gonna
i just want to say this i look at these
old pictures of everybody that had masks
on black and white
cats and [ __ ] and everything and they're
like oh well yeah for so long we have
eventually we're gonna get there yeah
when we don't know but it's good to see
you i'm glad you're healthy
same ditto you you had a little health
scare we're going to talk about here
in a minute but before we do please plug
everything all of it uh you know what
i'm doing right now is because of uh no
touring and no uh no tv right now so go
uh check out uh the whiskey ginger
podcast which you've been a guest on you
will be coming
back and then uh also bad friends with
me and bobby lee both of those shows
uh go check them out on the youtubes and
then wherever you can download audio
podcasts
andrewsantino.com it links you to all
that stuff anyway so
go check it out man that's been fun for
me to continue to do that stuff because
you know
that's all that's what we got going on
right now if we can't tour and i can't
shoot anything you know although i know
bobby did a commercial
i was mad and brendan neal called me and
did a commercial too him and kevin hart
were doing like a chase bank commercial
oh really yeah i was like what's going
on are you shooting now let me come by
let me walk around in the background
cash a check trying to get a little
check
chase can i get it can i get the song
can i get this on chase
no he um yeah they're two people i know
we're doing productions commercial stuff
like that but but nobody's got dave
nobody got no dave's not coming back
dave on fx isn't coming back until
can you uh stream that like binge that
right now hulu baby on hulu
maybe they made a big deal with hulu it
really is i do you're great in it dude
it's a fun show i hope i hope no we are
coming back 100
but we uh i'll tell you this i'm
probably not supposed to but it's fine
but we um you know the show did so well
uh
that they bragged about it fx bragged
about it they put out a press release
that was like
highest rated comedy they've ever had in
history in history wow
in the network's history yeah and uh
because they bragged about it of course
everybody was like oh so it did well
like yeah and we're like why aren't you
yeah right
[Laughter]
and they were like oh i mean we didn't i
didn't know it did we don't know if it
did that well
appreciate it i think they're pretty
proclaimed yeah yeah we're of course
we're we're begging them we're like
we're not gonna be able to shoot we're
not gonna be able to shoot so uh
help us out give us a little gift you
know because i think it's
i think they know everyone is waiting
we can't work i just we can't i can't
work nobody can work i'm already on a
contract with them
so even if i wanted to do something else
which doesn't even exist i would have to
ask them to let me out to do something
else
so they got me baby fx
got me i got you right now yeah so look
i want to talk about this because you
were like i don't know you had uh
papa had a fall you had a fall recently
papa had a fault let's talk about it and
bobby made fun of me for like an hour
and a half
on the phone what happened she went to
the hospital right i did
the next morning i should have gone at
night yeah i had to sleep it off
well what happened was i can see i got a
little scar here by the eye
um we had that earthquake two weeks ago
yeah i had been out during the day
all day in the sun and then that night i
went to my neighbor's house who i never
i've
we've never really hung out he was like
come over have a drink with this other
neighbor
nice guy i said yeah i'll come over i'll
have a drink so we had a couple of
drinks
and nothing unusual for me though i you
know i like to have a couple of
nothing big i wasn't we weren't we're
just drinking casually talking for like
three or four hours
so i go home uh i get in bed
everything is normal the earthquake is
like 3 30 or something like that and
four in the morning dude i popped up
so fast i mean because i hear stuff
breaking
my office used to be where we shot the
show
now we shoot it at a different so my
office is where i came i was at your
place that's right you came to a house
yeah
and now there's stuff everywhere in that
room because it's a dead room now it's
not
i moved everything out so there's
pictures on the floor there's stuff
leaning and
that's not put up all the way so stuff
was falling and breaking and that's i'm
panicking because i'm like oh my god in
my mind even though this isn't real
the dog had been in in my in our room
i thought the dog was in my office in my
mind i had this you know when you have
like a dream and you wake up and you're
like that's what's happening
it wasn't i think the dog is in the
office so i run into the office and as
i'm running in there
the earthquake and my dizziness and
getting up so fast and i'm sure liquor
in the blood is not good
right i give my [ __ ] oh bro
one two three i grab on i start getting
dizzy and i grab onto the wall and
there's the hallway bathroom is right
outside of our room
and i sit down on the toilet to catch my
balance because my head was
spinning you know and as i sat on the
toilet
i knew it i yelled out to her i go i'm
not feeling good
she and she and she's what out like a
like wait you were sitting and just
tipped forward asked out and i smacked
my face
against the corner of my sink yo so
lucky [ __ ] dude and it wasn't my eyeball
i missed my eye by
an inch so i smacked my face and i hit
my head on the floor
i was out i got passed out and and the
so i had fainted but
all right let me ask you a question
because i've knocked on what i've never
painted what do you are you seeing the
circle close like what are you feeling
feels really when you faint it feels
really warm like it feels really warm
and then you yeah you slowly it slowly
is like if you put a blanket over your
head like that
it's like it's like almost instantaneous
though
it feels like you could stop it your
mind is going your mind is going i'm
going to pass out i'm going to pass out
but it's
it's like you're you're not working fast
enough you're not working faster than
your brain is thinking
and i it must have hit my head on the
scene would you go like this
like that forward and then it fell flat
on the floor
you hit your head there shaking me
waking me up are you bleeding
not not as bad the cut was was the cut
was pronounced it was pretty
pretty deep but it wasn't blood wasn't
coming out which was weird
so i wiped it down we covered it up i
cleaned how long were you out
oh second i mean three seconds what did
it feel like
i've been i've been out a few times
[Music]
we're going to talk about i've been out
a few times
how about this time but this time when
you when you wake up you
always don't know like you know when you
see a fight if you ever see an mma fight
and you know when when when the moment
they wake up and they do this thing
where they're like
nothing's wrong why are you you know
yeah you think it's annoying that
they're
like well i'm fine leave me alone
immediately
i was like what what why are you
freaking out because she was yelling and
screaming and shaking me
and of course then i get up and i look
in the mirror and i saw that's what
happened because in my mind i thought i
went from the toilet to the ground
but i had i didn't know i hit my head my
face was warm was real hot
super super hot and that's when i looked
in the mirror and i saw this gash
on the side of my head and cleaned it up
and uh
we sat awake for a while talking about
it you know like are you okay is
everything okay i was okay
and the next morning and went to the e
it went to the uh urgent care
why to get my scope let me get my head
checked out you did what you were
what was something happening that you
were worried or just like no not at all
no nothing in fact because i and that
was the other thing the doctor was like
you didn't drink that much i mean
because i told her she was like
three drinks for a guy your size i mean
i'm six one 200 pounds yeah and i had a
couple of waters
so it's not like the liquor she was like
it was a combination of you getting up
and
i'm not an alcoholic or anything i got a
podcast called whiskey ginger i record
two three episodes
i drink a bottle a knife this ain't
nothing
lady no of course but i i alright so
wait how old are you now 36
so is anything starting to are you
worried that maybe you had a seizure
or nothing no because they checked me
all out okay she said it was a combo of
the alcohol in the blood and be in the
sun all day probably wasn't helping she
was she's like it wasn't
but you got up so fast that your blood
transfer right in fact
i read an article that my dad had sent
me that men in their 60s
have the most strokes and heart attacks
in the middle of the night from getting
up too fast to go
to piss so getting up so fast if you get
up too fast your blood
shifts there's a big blood shift from
when you're when you're laying at
resting position
and you're resting heart rate to when
you're active and so that's what happens
to older dudes they have strokes and
heart attacks in the middle of the night
when they get up to piss because
the blood shift well that's not my beef
but i got up too fast
had the blood shift in the middle of the
earthquake which you lose in your
equilibrium right people have
been right in the dark in the dark and
i'm running through the hallway so i'm
not paying attention i'm a little out of
it
and when i sit down on the toilet i must
have just lost all my i got up and down
and up and down too fast
so she did all my blood work and this is
my this is you know this is gonna like
this
she does she does on my blood work i
went to a good hospital does all my
blood work and she said well you should
take a cat scan
if you want she goes i you seem
perfectly fine i said my neck is so sore
and my neck felt like when you used to
get into a fist fight you know the next
day when you're like
i feel like a car accident and i said
well can i get a cat scan she goes uh
here we're imaging center is packed for
some reason we can't get you in but i
don't want you to wait
so we're gonna send you to panorama city
oh
i'm like no i know panda let me tell you
bro
no no i was like no and she was like you
got it that's the only one that was
available
let me tell you about panorama city this
is a very quick one i remember when i
first
moved here yeah okay uh and this was
god we're talking about you know i got
here in
the second time in 97 so this is honest
to god this is 2000 2001. we're talking
20 years ago yeah panorama city right i
had never i didn't know what the [ __ ]
was that sound
panoramic views south nice beautiful
someone gave me a walmart gift card
there are no walmarts out here in l.a
there's one up there but there's
one in panorama city and let me tell you
something i pulled into that
[ __ ] parking lot i was like i walked
through the
[ __ ] just on the floor knowing giving a
[ __ ] and i was like
i had never to this day i've never seen
anything like that
and that was absolute chaos that's what
that's what it looked like yeah i was
like if that hospital is anything like
that
they made me put the cat sand machine
together i had to put it together before
i got in that thing
i was so nervous i was so freaked out
man it was tripping i was like this is
so shady
so you went right from there to panorama
city like direct drive
got an imaging machine panicking the
whole time
and they called you within two hours to
let you know results and she said blood
came back
perfect she's like you're you're you
take care of yourself
you're juan gonzalez right like nah
man i'm andrew is this alejandro
santiago
it is okay by the way nobody
there was no english no english
she was annoyed i didn't speak spanish
when i checked in i was like they sent
me up here bro i didn't
bono i was out i was out of commission
so they called me and she said she she
said blood work was great she's like
you're healthy you're in shape all your
blood is good
and she's like you just got to just be
careful something like that you know
she's like
it's a freak accident but you're lucky
and the brain was all good too
nothing but like we said look i got some
lumps up there
i'm sure yeah because i've been i've
been out
five times maybe i worry about it i i
got knocked out in a fight
um but i got jumped but i was out for
hours
so that's dangerous i worry about the
longer you're around yeah
the worse it is yeah and literally it's
knocked out yeah woke up in a hospital i
woke up in a hospital
and that's when you're like well you
know what's going on and i just my eyes
were closed and the nurse was right here
i never
never knew what this lady looked like
but all she said was here's some ginger
ale
you have a major concussion just sip it
and i just i gulped i was so thirsty i
gulped it
and then from the concussion and
everything just puking where she's like
okay that's when you know it's bad when
you throw up they say if you throw up
then you're in trouble
yeah because i got you you went to sleep
a few times yeah yeah i did go to sleep
i know me too but they i don't they may
have told me not to but again
i don't i was concussed i don't remember
so i did concussion protocol
because of this and i she said i did not
have a concussion
i mean so you could have played next
sunday i gotta play all right i gotta
play that next morning
okay all right i would have showed up i
know you would make santino's here his
eyes got a wonky eye i'm looking the
other way
like let's go let's go he's got a
pronounced cut but he's good
it's pronounced but it's good
i was ready to rock no but they but she
said it was fine but i had been
concussed before so i knew it wasn't
concussion what's the first time you
went out was it knocked out passed out
what happened to you the first time you
said you'd been out a few times yeah
probably four or five
really oh yeah what's the first one i
fell out of a tree
so knocked out knocked out knocked out
fell on my head
um climbing not so high of a tree maybe
six feet seven feet off the ground the
limb was but i fell backwards on my head
but we were i was getting a uh i was
getting a wiffle ball that got stuck in
the tree
wiffle balls are bound to get stuck in
the tree i get up there
i'm look i'm reaching for it and i
slipped how many times did you climb
this tree or
climb trees prior to this right so
that's why i was being careless
and even if you did fall i you used to
fall out of a tree you'd land you'd be
fine
you know maybe land on yourself yeah
yeah you're fine but
i landed on the side of my neck and and
that i was out out and i was out
i don't really remember touched that
spot twice now so how do you know that
that was over here yeah that's where you
touched when you said you hurt your neck
you said my next hurdle that's why they
sent you to the point
this side
i think she did that just because she
didn't really like me that much she's
like the image
imaging center is full you got to get
your pan or they were all going out for
drinks and [ __ ] and she didn't want them
being late
she goes you know what i think it's full
i think that yeah i think we've got to
go i see them at jalapeno jacks or
whatever
yeah sure that's mine
yeah i fell out of a tree when i was 12
and
conked myself cold but you remember fall
do you remember the
missing brand what happened no i
remember like i remember slit i remember
the at the event but i don't remember
the specifics of when it happened i
think i told you on the other the last
time i was here i told you about
when i got knocked out in basketball i
think i remember i told you that story
you just made me remember a time i got
knocked out that i forgot i fell on my
neck i got my leg taken out from your
neck again
fell on my head on basketball hard i got
my legs taken out
so i felt backwards but i remember that
i remember getting up and i waited for a
sub
that's how that's how committed i was
bro i wait for a sub i go sub in
sub in and they were like sit down
sit down bro my step son uh it's this
one scared me he did the same thing in
high school a couple years ago he's
he's in that growth spurt he like every
time i see him he's taller now was he a
big boy
he's skinny as [ __ ] yeah he's six two or
three already at 17. like whoa
he's built like he's got that randy moss
build right now he's got to put like
he's got a swimmer's build he needs to
put some meat on him right
uh but he went up when he was
just starting to learn his height you
know he's starting to realize oh i might
be able to dunk
so he went up he dunked and he wasn't
used to
you know you're used to coming down in a
certain
you know he held on
and then slipped and his hands let go
because he he swung under
the momentum yeah boom right on his head
they and
you're at school they wouldn't let his
ass up they put him in the [ __ ] crazy
stretcher you know the thing
it scares the [ __ ] out of you it's just
protocol but they're wheeling them out
so now we joke about it but you know
that [ __ ] was scary when it happens it's
scary
yeah when it happens it's scary when i
fell in my neck my mom was panicked but
but of all the times i got knocked out i
think i told you that other story too
once
i think i told you when i got knocked
out in junior high football i got some i
got murdered
i think i told that on the show tonight
i don't remember it i look but i've been
knocked out twice
i forgot one of them you got some fatty
tissue i'm gonna tell you i was um
first time we went roller skating ever
to rink there was the main
yeah i don't know how old i'm under 10
but there's the main rink and then there
was a practice ring
sure practice rink was just a smaller
version but it had
for whatever reason metal you know like
rails oh guard rails
yeah in the middle that you could grab
yeah i remember that and i
just [ __ ] ate it and i woke up face
yeah crushed and then i woke up my my
dad's taking me to the
er to get you know same [ __ ] concussion
and all he's like yeah you got knocked
out
like i'm like from rollerskating how
long were you out
i was rolling probably longer than i
thought
i think exactly what i did i hit like
that temple area where you just go down
you're just down for a second you're
like what
sleeping yeah yeah but i wasn't i had
never roller skated so it wasn't like i
was like get off me i'm fine i knew i
was not
help me no i was like nah help me out
some [ __ ] just happened
i got smoked junior high football i got
knocked out helmet to helmet
that was bad and then i took a nap in
college i got knocked out in college
and a fighter yeah did you really i took
a nap
i want to hear all those we got we got
work we
got work we got work where were you we
were in an apartment complex in arizona
at arizona state uh and a dude was
had there was a dude that stormed out of
this party
and got in this car and almost hit uh
one of the
people that we were with and then it was
like got out of his car and was talking
because somebody smacked on his
hood or something like yo you know
there's a busy complex at night college
and he gets out of this car and he's
yelling and talking [ __ ] and someone
from where he just came from heard and
it was like
15 of them and like four of us and it
escalated within
seconds yeah it wasn't even like it was
college was like
you get older and you're like you're
taking your time you're like i don't
want to fight you i don't want to fight
either man
man let me just even stretch you know
you better huh yeah
let me i'm going to walk away i'm going
to come back i'm going to be the bigger
man
yeah no we just started swinging and
um it was inevitably like two on one
almost every one of us
my friend colin got it way worse i mean
he was he's a big boy he's a swinger he
was going after everybody he didn't care
he was he was he was tough but he got it
bad i mean he got his face scuffed up
because the concrete he went down to the
concrete
not the same for me i'm with my friend
travis and we're running around and
i see one and i don't see another one
and i got whooped on the back
i got hit in the back of the head
that'll knock you cold out at any time
yeah not the front the front you can
take a couple but i got hit in the back
of the head and i
woke up on rocks if you watch the nfl
anytime they hit the dude right here on
that side temple area good night you
just see him you see yeah well you see
the body goes
yeah i woke up on the rocks the rocks
yeah it was arizona but there's no yard
out there it's a bad place to fight
so was the fight over when you woke up
or was it still happening for me it was
dude i woke up i was gone bye
i'm out of here i started walking i
started walking the other way yeah
innocent innocent innocent i'm walking
we got we got bad and the next morning
we had
we had gone back to the dorms and we
probably had gotten high or drank our
our way through the night and were
bummed i mean everyone was really upset
yeah that's a tough help well we got we
got watched we got back
and the next morning we were out eating
breakfast or whatever looking around at
everybody i mean it was just
it was so sad man i mean like just loose
skin
busted lip you know like dried blood on
the neck you know
overeat the eggs of running down your
face meanwhile those guys are out there
having burritos
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor oh max
cryofreeze living with chronic pain is
the worst it's more than a feeling of
discomfort it can affect your whole life
many of you have probably had some type
of pain has prevented you from relaxing
and sleeping or
stopped you from exercising perhaps it's
been ongoing for a few weeks now and it
hasn't improved with any of the
treatments you've tried
enter omax health if you're looking to
get rid of nagging muscle joint
pain immediately while providing long
lasting recovery then you need to try
the natural breakthrough pain relief
solution cryo-free cbd roll-on developed
by omax health
this non-prescription triple action pain
relief roll-on
especially formulated to block pain
receptors reduce inflammation
and improve muscle and joint flexibility
and the best part is
this 100 natural cbd-powered remedy
works its magic within 10 minutes of
application
and relief lasts up to eight hours which
is much longer than the over-the-counter
products
i've been telling you guys since
december i've had this
pull in my neck i've been pumping that
stuff on it
if you've watched my elbow has been
getting numb and stuff and that omax
boom oh it's gone omax health is
offering my listeners 20
off a full body cryo-free cbd pain
relief roll-on plus free shipping
now this discount also applies towards
any product site-wide so just go to
omaxhealth.com today
and enter code honeydew that's
omaxhealth.com and enter code honeydew
to get 20 off cryofreeze and sitewide
our next sponsor is upstart now during
these economically turbulent times
everyone's looking for a way to feel
more financially secure and i don't
blame you so if you're still needlessly
throwing money
every month at high interest credit card
debt it's time you checked out upstart
the revolutionary online lending
platform that knows
you're more than just a credit score now
is the time to find out how low
your upstart rate can be to help pay off
high interest credit card debt
now unlike other lenders upstart can
reward you based on your education and
your job history in the form of a
smarter rate so you don't need a degree
or diploma to apply though
upstart lets you skip going to the bank
because it's completely online
they offer loans from a thousand to
fifty thousand so you can consolidate
your debt into one easy
fixed rate payment upstart makes it fast
and simple to check your rate and since
it's just a soft pull
it will not affect your credit score the
hard pull happens
if you accept your rate and proceed with
your application and the best part
if the loan is approved and accepted
most people get their funds the very
next business day now over 400 000
people have used upstart to pay off
credit cards
or meet their financial goals and i know
quite a few you have man you guys hit me
up and say it's the easiest thing you've
ever done it's the best thing you've
ever done
and i appreciate you supporting the show
and
i'm telling you if there are people out
there that did it you should hit them up
and let people know about it
and free yourself from the burden of
these high interest credit card debt and
get back to using your money
your way with upstart see why upstart
has a 4.9 out of 5 rating on trustpilot
and hurry2upstart.com honeydew to find
out how low your upstart rate can be
checking your rate only takes a few
minutes that's upstart.com slash
honeydew
now let's get back to the do yeah i'm a
little something no so we got so we yeah
that was probably my
fourth or fifth time that i had been put
to bed sports mostly were the things
that put me to bed
almost always i got hurt in sports doing
something stupid
i knocked a guy out and this oh my god i
knocked the guy out for so long
i actually got emotional about it
because i didn't know if i really heard
him yeah
this pothead that used to come around
freshman year who wasn't even in our
school you know he was like dropping off
weed
and you're like hey man like what
classes are you in he's like i'm 38 you
know like he wouldn't
it's like i'm like oh [ __ ] i thought you
were in school
he was like uh he's he said um i saw you
guys hooping the other day at the gym i
should
uh out outside he's like i should have
um i should have said i should have said
what's up i wanted to play he goes
he's like you can jump can you play um
have you ever played uh
ultimate frisbee and i said nah that's
not really for my [ __ ] you know he's
like come try one night so of course
one night i was bored and i was like
i'll go over there it's monday or
whatever it was i go over there
is that the [ __ ] i see on uh
sportscenter stuff where those dudes are
crazy diving
on a football field right yes and we've
used a practice on asu's men's
practice field they used to let them
play out there so we would go out there
and hit with bright lights it was great
in the middle of the night they'd leave
those lights on until like a
midnight because it was for red it was
by the rec center which is not there
anymore
but i'm learning the game and as i'm
learning i'm loving this [ __ ]
because i'm i was a little bit more
athletic than most of these dudes these
are what is the
is there what are the rules is it like
any other sport out there that you once
you catch it you can only take like one
two step well you can take two steps on
the catch
and you can't move then you have to stay
in your spot and pass it right
but you throw it and as you catch it you
can take two steps as you land and then
you have to throw it again
you know does it like basketball but
without advancing with a dribble
you get it you're allowed two steps and
then it's kind of like it's kind of like
uh
but but but football in mindset right
because you have to get into an end zone
right yeah so i'm learning it and i'm
loving it and then i'm learning i can
jump pretty
i can jump pretty [ __ ] high i've
always been able to jump and i've always
been able to like
kind of leap out of my shoes well
there's a dude he's
much shorter than me and there's a
there's a frisbee going way towards the
end zone and i'm like oh i'm picking
this off
for sure like there's no doubt i
jump at the same time he jumps and as
i'm grabbing it my elbow
hits him cold in the face i mean i don't
know if i hit him in the eye what i
don't know where
but i went like this to grab it out of
the air and poof like that
dude i knocked him out in midair i mean
i almost heard him snore
he was in the air as he went down
and he smoked his head yeah that's
what's
it's that the balance yeah snap
right so he bounced and everyone was
screaming at me and i'm just thinking
hey man i just went for the thing
because they said i was being reckless i
don't
they were playing a little bit softer
it's ultimate frisbee man
that ain't just some regular frisbee
yeah this ain't regular bee bro
altibee all right bulls i didn't sign up
for this
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] yeah so of course i i i
felt bad but then dude he was out
i don't know two minutes three minutes i
mean it was bad that's a long time we
were standing there the whole time and i
started to have a little bit of a panic
because i was like holy [ __ ] breathing
though
yeah he was breathing but he kept like
he was mumbling and
it was bad dude you see piece of his
brain trying to put it back together you
know
there's definitely a brain damage oh bad
yeah and of course then they call in
ambulance again eminence calm and
i felt so guilty dude i felt so guilty
as i [ __ ] this guy up all right next
man up
sup this is why we keep 15 on the roster
get him out get him out get him in let's
go did he wave somebody in for him
[ __ ] no yeah get up
i felt so bad for knocking this little
dude out i smoked i
smoked him with my elbow and look at
these things i mean this is
a pickaxe i mean i got bony elbows
nailed him in the
cat was bad that i regret i
regret i feel bad i shouldn't have got
well because you know when you know in
sports when you're going up against
somebody that you're gonna
you know you've got the advantage i knew
i could have played it a little bit
safer
i probably was trying to show off
because i didn't need to jump as early
as i jumped i didn't need to backflip
you know what i'm saying i got it i'm
gonna be outside
after i knock him out and break dancing
on top of him hey
hey i need to do the worm next to him
while
in sports though you know when you have
the upper hand you got it it's like you
just
you want you want to show up a little
bit when you're like oh i know i can
beat this guy
whatever that is i i'm 100
with you if it was a man on the field it
didn't matter to me i i was always like
you playing a co-ed softball league
you'd see that one [ __ ] dude
like we had a guy yeah in a co-ed
softball league one time he was pitching
and this girl's round in third it's a
co-ed
softball let it go bro bro did not let
it go and he
[ __ ] charged him with that ball and
he held it in the midst so that he could
lower his shoulder and
not drop and he he he [ __ ] broke that
girl's collarbone sure
and man we piled on that [ __ ]
but he was one of those it's sports like
it's
it's co-ed softball like if this was a
bunch of dudes and you did that
first of all you wouldn't have done that
if that was a dude no yeah no that you
wouldn't have done that that's what's so
funny though
i played in a league i played in the
men's league anybody who plays softball
i don't know what it is about softball
but men's softball they're all
stretching for something
they want the old days back so it got so
competitive we ended up quitting
our team we won we i think we won the
championship in the league
yeah we kind of think we won the
championship well because we got we got
we got
it was so tumultuous by the end of it we
didn't want to do it anymore we
we we got in arguments uh fights people
would leave
i mean it was endlessly fighting they
didn't like it
we were good we had a bunch of young
good guys but we would bring wooden bats
and you they all hit aluminum and they
were like yeah you can't use wood and i
was like
what's gonna go less that's right yeah
to your advantage they didn't like us to
using wood but we all loved
i loved hitting a wood bath yeah so we
all brought wood and they complained
endlessly i was like this goes
less for the aluminum goes way further
when you
and it was 16 inch no glove so the ball
you know oh yeah they're huge
you hitting that far with the wooden bat
is tough but we liked wood
just because i i like the feel of wood i
just it's to me i feel like you could
have more control with wood
well they hated us for that and so that
every time we would get into some kind
of fighter argument
and and there was only and there was
only an
ump a one rotating up because it was a
cheap league so you had to make your own
calls half of the time
oh god this just sounds like fist fights
at every base
yeah of course of course it was
happening he's out he's it he's out
fight all the time i had to quit i
couldn't do it anymore i was like this
was too much but it was 16-inch no glove
chicago softball that's what they play
back home no gloves you know jamming
fingers all day
and it's nothing but arguments over you
know
who's out and who's in and and and and
the pitches was always a debate over
whether that was a structure right i had
to quit i got
i got so over it i was like um i don't
want there's no men's sport i want to
play anymore
in an organized league i'll play pick up
basketball i'm not playing an organized
game ever again
no i'm done i'm done i got no need also
you want to get hurt
you want to get hurt and be that guy
because
it's not necessarily that there's
anything wrong it's that it's that
[ __ ] out there that wants to hit you
with the blind side
or do some [ __ ] to you know yeah
yeah and then you end up you know what's
up bro we're just playing bro
you were playing you were there i i i
didn't see i didn't see you there
i didn't know my bad that ass that's
your ankle yeah
i i got over the idea of feeling good
i think i i don't know if i told you i
keep thinking saying i think i told you
but
i was in charlotte and uh i wanted to go
play ymca
i want to go play pick up basketball
just for some exercise i actually went
to go shoot by myself
you're on the road and just wanted to
get out yeah i just want to go shoot
because i usually i run
i run every day and it was so hot i was
like damn i gotta go i'm gonna go in the
gym and i'm gonna go shoot and just kind
of run around the track
there's a game going on and all these
kids are you know young
15 16 17 year old athletic black kids i
mean just
unfucking real jumping out of the gym
and [ __ ] and one dude sees me and he's
like hey yo
you you want a hoop and i was like no
i'm i'm good man i don't i have tennis
shoes i didn't even have
he goes oh come on man we need one and i
was like all right
you ain't wearing those bike shorts for
nothing but
i got i go these got underwear inside of
them so i should be good yeah these have
a mesh lining i think i gotta go
all right i get over there
i'm feeling i'm gonna keep it i'm
feeling it i'm feeling right away
i'm feeling it right having a good time
just in the huddle and [ __ ] just i'm
feeling good they're letting me in their
circle i'm dishing a little bit you know
i dropped i dropped a couple of shots i
was like oh [ __ ]
all right i'm feeling okay well we come
around the next break
sure enough yeah this is a young 15 year
old [ __ ]
just athlete takes off from like the
third hash mark
because lebron james is right on my
[ __ ] face i mean
i'm not even i'm not even defending this
is nuts right oh yeah i'm not even
defending him i turned to just get up in
the air a little bit and it's just like
my his dick and my arm just fused to my
face
i think that was a charged guy it's a
thought of charge
but they the gym went nuts you know oh
oh
don't got that old ass red head oh [ __ ]
you don't got open tight look he got
he got howdy dude he got his ass dunked
up i got [ __ ] on for like 25 minutes
[Laughter]
trying to regain some [ __ ] i'm
sitting on the side i'm like good game
man good game and nobody
not one kid wanted to say good game to
me nobody really man
go back to the hotel i don't need to
play that [ __ ] i was like i'm done
[ __ ] your show tonight too man it's
unfunny [ __ ] trying to give us
free tickets
they got me bad yeah i was the joker
that was the joke of the night yeah they
were all waiting but i'm glad i could
give that to him i was like okay
that's for your igs everybody that's for
your ig story yeah i made it
i'm sure i made a story definitely wrong
because you know he because you know he
was
he was dribbling up cork turning his he
turned to his friend he was like
yes watch this turn it off
yeah that was the end of my uh publix uh
pickup that's it right it's done yeah
i'll play horse
i'll play something i love like horses
yeah some driveway horse
yeah i'm not even going to the gym i'm
doing driveway horse that's
it i'm about off the [ __ ] garage roof
yeah and
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh speaking of roofs
you i want to jump to that because you
had to fix your what's something happen
with fixing your roof
yeah bro i'm up there my room i had to
fix my roof
because we had a leak we we we got the
house and of course as you know
everybody jokes you know it's like ozil
never ends a money pit yeah
the first rainstorm we had in our living
room just
the ceiling [ __ ] came through yeah
real bad didn't damage anything in the
house
but it ruined everything that up so we
thought we got a side patch job done
um this guy you know tarps up there is
he gonna let dry out then we'll look at
it with the rain kept coming the rain
rains here for like three weeks and then
never again yeah yeah i mean this is
like window
gone so when it's all said and done
we're trying to get the roof fixed
and of course this dude is up there
fixing the roof
and i'm thinking okay all should be good
now
we're all good he said well give me the
hose i got to put the hose up here to
show
he said no leak on the unit you know
he's uh he's japanese yeah yeah he said
give me the horse i throw the horse and
i throw up the hose and he goes
okay you should be good go inside and
look he's got the hose turned on high
i mean it's as if it's just coming into
the house
i'm like bro no way
yes dude yes he he thought so
the problem was the air conditioning
unit guys didn't communicate with the
roofing guys they needed to fix the
shell at the exact same time because
here in l.a
people some people wherever you're
watching this might not know we put a
lot of them old houses put hvacs on the
roof
you don't do that right yeah you don't
do that right where i'm from
it's on the floor yeah it's outside of
the house outside the big fan unit
next to that this is on our roofs a lot
of these old houses have them on the
hvacs on the roof
and our old ass roof supporting a 10-ton
unit
you know and so pieces had collapsed
around well what they fixed didn't fix
the
shell of the unit so it had just cracked
more because they were up there
[ __ ] with it i mean they put a crane
up there lifted it up they must not have
put the pressure right
so i gotta i i fixed a hole in my
[ __ ] ceiling in my living room three
times now
i mean i feel like i'm gonna what did
the dude do did he come back
he didn't come back and figure no no he
goes oh mom you gotta talk to the guy
then do the
air conditioning didn't give a [ __ ] yeah
i don't know man it's gotta be the unit
we fix our part you know
okay i'm playing this juggling game of
whose fault it is you know
he says it's you guys no i mean we fixed
our that you know he couldn't
his la his lack of concern was almost
beautiful when i showed him i said
i told him that's an art isn't it oh
couldn't he came down he came down and i
showed him
the damage from inside he's like yeah
you know
he's gonna dry he's okay he's gonna dry
i'm like but i
i have to live through all this this
[ __ ] he's like yeah you know what are
you gonna do you gotta call the ac guy
you know he's gonna fix it so
they passed the buck and so now i'm
living with i have another hole in my
roof now
dry because no rain but i have to live
with that
every day so when whenever i can get a
guy to come out and [ __ ] get up in
the air yeah
during corona you want to come out
during rona and get in my [ __ ] attic
get asbestos
it's impossible man i'm [ __ ] so i'm
gonna live with a hole in the middle of
my [ __ ] ceiling
but the beauty of it is the beauty of it
is
uh i've come at peace with my house
stuff
i swear to god i've finally been like
okay i can't help it
i was arguing about stuff with the old
lady all the time about like well we
gotta in this is [ __ ] up in this [ __ ]
and now i'm like it's okay i get why
parents at some point
uh they just like relinquish this anger
that they're like it is what it is
i'm not gonna fix all that [ __ ] all that
you can't fix all the things all no
and you're gonna have a piece you can't
listen yeah let me tell you
i'm gonna tell you what my friend that
had a kid young told me
you can't have nice [ __ ] it's all for
kids it's
don't yeah don't bother going and buying
a five thousand dollar couch because
your kids are going to piss on it
[ __ ] on it craw color on it crawl on it
walk on it cut it
right yeah just get the 200 just get the
[ __ ]
cheapest comfortable thing i know now
that i'm well i mean i don't really like
fancy [ __ ] anyway but it just like
i stopped caring as much about
particulars about being like
because i'm a really nitpicky ocd guy me
too dude the anxiety yeah
well i gotta get this done in this room
and this is out of the house anymore
i've i've learned to go
oh this is out of control i can't
control all this that's crazy to think
i'm gonna be able to like
fix this fix that fix that even i can
fix stuff with my own hands but at some
point you're like
i don't even want to waste the time and
the money getting a guy because it's
manageable without it
you know what i'm saying it's not like
it's not like the electrical is broken
or the it's just there's a small
[ __ ] that i can't help it's cosmetic
something [ __ ] yeah even if it's not
even if it's like certain functionality
you know what i mean like one of the
doors doesn't lock all the way it's like
we figured it out you know like yeah
we've got another secondary lock in
there i was like oh yeah
the jam doesn't fit because this chain
i'm like all right man well then put a
[ __ ] board underneath that or
something
i don't know like fix it just temporary
fixes
you learn why people do that with houses
that they just temp fix stuff because
it's a pain in the ass dude at some
point i've let it go so
in my heart the hole is staring me down
when i'm watching tv at night but i'm
like
it's okay i just gotta let that [ __ ] go
so i've learned to like
let it go put into perspective you know
what i mean like it's not that big of a
deal
no especially with everything going on
right now yeah so that's what i mean
it's not that big
you used to drive me bananas this thing
before the pandemic was like
you know i'd be calling i'd be on the
road being like did you get the roof guy
to come
yeah well why isn't he there
no need it was like let it go let it go
let it go am i yelling at her for an
hour you know
i let it go i've learned i've learned to
let it go
um tell me about tampa what's this tampa
story
that's why i don't know how many stories
i've shared with you about because we
did a lot of we did so much talking
about sports and injuries that's why i
thought maybe it was the same one
i have a scar on my leg that's about two
inches long from tampa
um and if this is a repeat from the
first time we did this uh
then that's okay well just i don't
remember it i don't remember it either
but i
tell so many stories in so many podcasts
but with you it's sports are injury
related for some reason we did
you know trauma bro well i came out of
the i came out of the tampa improv
and uh oh this wasn't even a sports
thing no well to me life is a sport my
friend so i never give up
fair enough i come out of the tampa
improv and there's a fight that breaks
out
and long elongated story short i grab a
woman
who's falling pretty much into me and i
grab her
and what's the f after your show like
bouncer is in an argument with a guy
who's leaving i'm outside saying hi to
people
yes and a guy is in an argument with the
bouncer because i'm sure he's too [ __ ]
up and my guess is he's trying to take a
drink out of the room
which we've seen before yeah hey man put
it you know and they're trying to take
that hurricane glass out bro
come on man come on that's 14.
these bouncers want to fight yeah
they're paid to fight they're paid to
fight they're just sitting there
most times not able to yeah yeah and
that's why they're always crossing their
hearts right
yes
[Music]
so he's they're shuffling him out and
they're fighting they're scrapping with
him and they call security and the
people are getting pushed out of one
door you could exit out of that side
door
because the second show was coming to
the front well i'm on the patio and it's
pitch black i can't see a goddamn thing
and a woman
is being like pushed into me and i'm
like whoa whoa whoa i grabbed this lady
and as i'm stumbling i stumble like you
know to not cause myself to fall
and i smack my leg on something i can't
see and it hurts like a [ __ ]
but i kind of just let it go it was an
umbrella stand without an umbrella those
metal
like a commercial umbrella yeah you know
it's only
a foot and a half off the ground i can't
see that it's pitch dark
well the night's going on and i think
nothing of it but it's
throbbing i'm painful about an hour goes
by and i feel that my sock is wet
because there's no cut in my jeans i
lift up my jeans well it had gone it had
cut my skin yeah it punctured my skin i
was bleeding into my [ __ ] socks
and i don't know if you know about tampa
but you know you know
tampa's hospital uh panorama city
panorama city 2.0
yeah bro i go in i'm blee i'm i'm
profusely bleeding
and the woman is like yeah i can't do
nothing about it nothing
she was it's on the shin they didn't
give a [ __ ] she goes wrap it
just wrap it up i can't butterfly it
it's right on the shoe it's literally
right on my shin the scar's like this
big
and i go back to the hotel and i've
wrapped it up
so tight and in the middle of the night
i'm shuffling around i must have moved
around so much the wrap came undone
i soaked a hotel bed and blood for real
dude so much more blood than i've ever
seen in my entire holy [ __ ] it was
it was like there was a [ __ ] murder
scene i'm trying i was checking out that
day so i'm sure the woman was like
oh boy you want to turn down i'm like
yeah you gotta [ __ ]
i ble i bled out that i mean it bled out
of the mattress so much it had gone i
mean it had gone through to the mattress
i bled so much through the sheets
and i had this then i went and got it
checked out when i got here same thing
they couldn't stitch it
and it because it kept opening up it's
on my [ __ ] shin it would be like
something small oh my god there's
nothing to it
and finally a week or two later it
finally started to really
like heal up itself but i have a
permanent scar now because of tampa
that's and then when i look at it i
always
that's tampa in my mind was that for the
rest of my life was like
that would happen in [ __ ] tampa i
don't hate taste
it's just that would happen in tampa
some dumb [ __ ]
you know i like i remember like i don't
have a bad taste about tampa but
it was such a weird world that city
eboor is so strange it's like
you can still smoke inside at bars which
blew my [ __ ]
yeah and this was how many years ago
four or five i mean they could still
smoke
chickens are in the street roosters are
all in the [ __ ] streets scientology's
uh uh what's it called for uh is there
headquarters yeah but what's the one the
sea
org that's where it is right around the
corner
and it's cigar avenue because of all the
all the cubans that used to be there and
ebony
it's this beautiful mix of complete
chaos and misunderstanding of what it is
and this injury sums up tampa to me
a [ __ ] shin split on an umbrella
stand
in this confusing land you know what i
mean that's what tampa
that was my that was my last cut up i
think that's my
that's my last like major injury from
something stupid
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our next sponsor raycon
i've been using my raycons all the time
now especially during quarantine i've
been listening to tommy lee's singles
i've been listening to your mom's house
podcast i've been listening to a lot of
stuff right now and the best way to
listen
is using a pair of premium wireless
earbuds especially if you can get them
at less than half the price of the other
guys that's why i recommend wireless
earbuds
from raycon i use them to travel i use
them to exercise
i love them i actually got a second pair
and my stepson took him he took him i
i he won't even give him back like he i
hit him up how they working
and he's like they're great you're never
going to see him again
uh so raikon's newest model the one he
took from me is the everyday e25 ear
buds and they are the best ones yet
they have six hours of play time
seamless bluetooth pairing
more bass a compact design and a noise
isolating fit
raycon earbuds are stylish and discrete
there's no dangling wires or stems
the company was co-founded by ray j and
celebrities like
snoop dogg brandy mike tyson
and they are obsessed with the products
give them a try raycon has a 45 day free
return policy so you can make sure
they're the pair
of wireless earbuds for you for a
limited time
you can get 15 off your order at buy
ratecon
dot com slash honeydew that's b u y
r a c o n dot com slash honeydew for a
special 15
discount on raycon wireless earbuds make
sure to check it out now while the
deal's running
by raycom.com honeydew let's tell you
about our next sponsor talk space now
change is always a constant these days
it feels like there's something new to
grapple with
every day we may be adjusting to this
new normal but it's still stressful
it's important to talk about it and seek
support talk space online therapy is
here to give you that support because we
all need it right now
match with a licensed therapist from the
comfort of your own device and reach out
24
7 whenever something's on your mind
you'll hear back daily
five days a week it's affordable it's a
fraction of the cost of in-person
therapy but with talk space you can send
unlimited messages to your therapist and
they'll engage with you at least five
days a week and that means you never
have to wait to share
what's on your mind it's secure it's
private they're using the latest
encryption technology
to store client information look the
bottom line is that we all need someone
to talk to and talkspace wants to give
the license support we deserve at a
price we can afford
as a listener of this podcast you can
get 100
off your first month on talkspace to
match with your perfect therapist go to
talkspace.com
or download the app and you want to make
sure to use the code honeydew
to get a hundred dollars off your first
month and show your support for the show
that's honeydew
and talkspace.com now let's get back to
the do
you know you know i want to ask you this
because you obviously were angry growing
up about still
what was your the first fight that you
ever really got into
who was it what do you remember well i
fought when i fought when i was a kid a
bunch i would just fight people
to make fun of me but no i mean when i
was like do you remember like
one that i remember junior high fight
the youngest fight was probably like uh
yeah i mean i don't know i would punch
kids that said i was that made fun of
the redheaded thing
that i would just fight kids punch when
i was in uh kindergarten or first grade
my mom
remembers i a kid was teasing me
and pushed me and i took a toy like a
[ __ ]
train like a wooden train and i smoked
him in the face with it
and i cut his face open he's got a
pronounced cut right here for the toy
train man
i took his ass to panorama city i put
him in the cte machine
he was fine but it was all no it was
always i was always
ready to i was always ready i was way
skinny i was so skinny when i was a kid
i was lanky and i just i loved just
defending myself because i thought
well i'm not they're not gonna make fun
of me because i'm definitely gonna fight
back
and so it ended that streak of people
then i learned to make fun of them back
and i was always
clever or funnier than them or quicker
than them so people ended up
that stopped at some point teasing me
because i would just [ __ ] on them
and i realized that was better than
fighting them because fighting them
never got
i mean i mean i yeah we had an older kid
across the way but i'm so
glad i'm so glad i got my ass but
it teaches you so much about life like
there's this
person who doesn't know you and is ready
to take you the [ __ ] out like it does
something to you when you see someone
charging you're like there's a million
thoughts going through your head like oh
[ __ ] it changes your and changes the
dynamic of humanity do you you
you think about humans differently yes
you do you start to like scale yourself
a little bit and then you get older and
you're like wonder what the [ __ ] was
going on in that kid's house that he
beat me up every [ __ ] day yeah
well
i remember like i lost but i always
fought
you know when i was younger i always
fought but also it got to the point
where
some people were like well he's i know
he's gonna fight you know bullies don't
want
the fight never and i know he's gonna
fight back and even if i'm older and
stronger this [ __ ] is gonna
where it's gonna be 30 minutes
you know what i mean like it's gonna
take me a lot i'm just not gonna [ __ ]
with it yeah i want the easy push-over
kid that's what bullies want
they want to be you know bullies well
they don't i think bullies ever want to
fight
it's funny the kids that were the best
at fighting were
the ones that sat there and took it for
so long
for it yeah i've seen some of those
videos on youtube
where there's this kid getting bullied
he just takes he finally loses it he
just picks this kid up like by the
throat
you know what i mean and that kid goes
down like just lifeless
yeah he just walks away i'm like that's
what i'm talking about that kid right
there
it's someone that's got something
harvard inside of them that they don't
want to fight
the more people that are like i don't
want to fight they're probably pretty
good at fighting
because they just said like i don't want
i don't need this but then their defense
mechanism kicks in
i think bullies bullies who p people who
like pick fights there was always guys
like picked fights
i think they just loved the attention
and they wanted
they wanted the negativity in the chaos
cause that's obviously a reflection of
whatever else is going on in life right
like you said what's going on at home
something bad yeah if you got if you're
if you we all knew we were friends with
kids that had shitty shitty shitty
things at home
and they always were so [ __ ] up so
troubled so dangerous so like
they're reckless you know like they just
didn't give a [ __ ] anymore
because what's this this can't be worse
than my dad smacking my mom around
no [ __ ] or me around yeah that's
right that's usually how that goes when
you see that you're like man this poor
[ __ ] he'll never make it out
alive
yeah we had a friend that would just he
was that guy in college that would just
you know if you were sleeping on the
couch at the beach he'd just burn your
feet with a cigarette
you know what i mean like literally
you're asleep you just put it right on
your feet and it would be
it was [ __ ] up it would make me laugh
because it's not me but they would be
screaming at them but they would know
like
what am i gonna do to this kid that's
not happening you know what i mean he's
already damaged
yeah this dude's already broken he's
burning you with cigarettes
but that's really funny by the way
cigarette on the feet is hilarious don't
fall asleep around me babe
you'd be laying on the couch or your
bare feet up at the beach and he'd just
be sitting there playing a video again
with cigaretty d
ah what the [ __ ] man
put in [ __ ] did you ever did you ever
know people that did that should they
put a cigarette out on them to prove
like how tough they were
on their tongue obviously the song thing
like i saw kids do that all the time i
knew guys that would do it on their hand
i thought that was [ __ ] hardcore
there's something i saw at a party one
time that i just
it bothers me to this day it's probably
a reason it didn't happen but it bothers
me to this day that it didn't happen
and i wasn't the one given the
opportunity but there was this [ __ ]
dick just running his mouth to everyone
talking [ __ ] to the women you know just
being a real [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] to everybody and one guy
said something to him and he was like oh
is that right and he gets on his knees
and he puts his
hands behind his back and he's like i'll
give you the first [ __ ] shot
and i was like
like oh you oh that's on his knees and
it intimidated that guy that he didn't
do anything so that's what i thought you
[ __ ] [ __ ] and he stood up and i just
thought
god i would have punted your i would
have punted your
[ __ ] head i would have punted that
[ __ ] across the goddamn room you
know what i mean like i'm like you're
going
eddie put his put his chin up put his
hands behind his back
closed his eyes he got on his knees and
i was like oh please can i come
time out back up let me get i'm gonna
get a running start you got it what's up
i wouldn't have punted that [ __ ]
he would have been
it probably would have killed him he
called that dude's bluff huh he did hard
jesus
christ in front now i've never forgotten
that and i've also simultaneously
been mad at that guy for not doing it
because i really wanted to see that guy
shut the [ __ ] up but also like man how
come that one didn't swing myself
yeah i know because you would have done
it punch that's what i would have kicked
you're right i would have kicked him
right up on that [ __ ] chin
busted all his teeth out and everything
yeah yeah i uh and i've got a lot of
chipped
i've chipped teeth from sports and
fights and stuff yeah
this is my newest chip what happened to
that right this is new orleans
i went to a bachelor party in january
yeah
well probably the last one i'll ever go
to um i went to a bachelor party in
january
with a good friend we had such a great
time
uh we're we're we're doing mushrooms
we're drinking we're smoking we're
having a great time we went to a
pelicans game
we had so much fun with taking boats on
the bayou i mean it's like one of the
best weekends i've had in a long time
then we're having a crawfish boil and
i'm [ __ ] ripped
i'm lit up i'm on everything i'm [ __ ]
lit up i'm on it
i'm on everything we're pouring the crap
we're pouring uh
we're pouring the uh crawfish on the on
the table
potatoes sausage you know i'm
watching uh i'm watching
wasn't the super bowl yet no it was it
was super bowl yeah it was the super
bowl because we went inside then
the afternoon we watched from the inside
so i'm i'm outside we're on this patio
and i'm watching tv and as i'm taking
i'm you know taking off some d
shelling and i'm eating and i'm not
really watching i'm just doing it it's
like second nature you know well
i hadn't taken a shell off all the way
and i had put it in my mouth
and i bit down on a shell and it chipped
my [ __ ] friend
how the [ __ ] did the shell do that i
don't know did you feel it come out
right away oh yeah
right away i was like my buddy's like
what was i gonna chip my [ __ ] tooth
i was also lit up so but i must have bit
down hard on it and i cracked right
through it right in my front [ __ ]
tooth
and i did that thing i looked in the
mirror and i was like oh no dude
i did the same [ __ ]
gonna get this [ __ ] fix i called my
old lady drunk i'm like i chipped my
tooth on a crawfish shell she's like oh
my god oh my god but no [ __ ] we went to
get shrimp po boys the next day
i said this on stage the next day we go
to get shrimp po boys and
if you ever chip a tooth you play with
it a little bit because you kept oh you
can't you can't stop feeling it all you
can do
and i'm in line i'm doing this you know
i'm like oh they're driving me nuts
and the guy behind the counter i get up
to i get up and he's ready take my order
and he goes
he goes what's up with your mouth
because he sees me i'm doing it kind of
like erratically like you probably think
i'm a [ __ ] crackhead you know i'm
like
i love that he's asking you what's up
with you that's new orleans yeah yeah
that's right literally
yeah i said i said i chipped my tooth he
goes for real i said [ __ ] my tooth
like i chipped my tooth uh i was [ __ ]
up you know i'm drinking and
and smoking weed and eating crawfish i
chipped it on a crawfish shell he goes
oh
yeah that's new orleans just like that
real real casual yeah that's new orleans
like it was no like
i heard that i feel that it gave me some
silence i was like oh okay cool yeah
cause in his mind he was like yeah
that's some dumb [ __ ] that does happen
when you're [ __ ] up in new orleans
chewing on crawfish
for no i mean i for some reason too i
remember
the moment it was happening i i feel
like i knew
it was going to happen do you know what
i mean when i was like oh my god i could
have stopped it if i just looked down
and what was it wasn't my i was just
putting [ __ ] in my mouth not paying
attention and i just
bit down too hard got caught in my front
tooth and then fell right off
i called him my dentist he was like ooh
that's going to be tough to bond his
right on the cut too so that's exactly
what happened to me but yeah like a
bigger [ __ ]
i had a [ __ ] key chain and it come
just a little bit apart so i put it in
my
mouth and like i had a bunch before and
perfectly balanced it
and to gently bite it down and it
slipped and it
carved out the front just like that but
here is what was funny
if you looked at it straight on you
couldn't see it
if i tilted my head just just you could
see a [ __ ]
cut like a [ __ ] you know i mean
like if i if i
if i level-headed you the whole yeah
you'd never see it
i couldn't even i couldn't even give you
a what nothing i just had to stay still
you smile but what's up it was a cut
that hit so it dug
into the front and cut under you know
what i mean like yeah
got a piece so same thing i go to the
dentist he's like this is gonna be tough
he bonded this [ __ ] it's still
there this is why
i even want to wipe my teeth this one
gets a little it's still a touch
yellower yeah but it's a real tooth
though it's still my real
good but he put a bigger because of
where it is he had to cover more of the
tooth with it so that
really all i have is a cut like that in
there but it looked
it just looked so [ __ ] all i could
think was hillbilly yeah
it looks so [ __ ] hillbilly and i
couldn't stand looking i i'll just go
i'm like what the [ __ ] you biting keys
if you have good teeth
now at this point i don't give i think
i'm going to leave it honestly
it's so small i wouldn't even notice it
if you didn't say something but now you
do
yeah yeah i think i'm at a point in my
life when i i'm leaving
i don't give a [ __ ] it's the sunscreen
on the nose i'm not rubbing that [ __ ] in
zinc it's zing for my white ass i used
to be embarrassed about that
rub it in now i'm like leave it on [ __ ]
it leave it on i gotta get protection
but yeah i know i uh that was that was
this was a a reminder that as i get
older
uh i'm caring less and less about i
like i i would have panicked about that
10 years ago and that would have been on
my i had to get to a dentist now
i don't think i give a [ __ ] i'll say
that of the silver lining
of this virus and it's shoving us all
into our homes and
literally turning a mirror on society
and showing us
what [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] we are on
planet earth in outer space from the
the racism the riots the murders the
politics the
religion everything we are just not
doing a great job as human beings on
this planet
it has really been like wow we we're
just bad like collectively when you look
at it you're like god damn y'all we got
to do a better job
yeah i think we don't i think we just
don't uh i think we've proven that we um
that a lot of people don't care about
anybody but themselves which by the way
your prerogative it's a
sad existence but it's a bummer it's a
bummer that a lot of people are like
it's about me man all right you know i'm
not saying
give up your whole life for strangers
i'm not saying that i'm just saying like
small sacrifices and small thoughts
about other people to me
this seems like this would be a
no-brainer like oh come on man this is
we can knock something like this out
that's why i'm excited to do these
scholarships we're going to do here at
the music center and stuff yeah i want
to help kids out you know i want to help
you know look man we were talking about
this before all i've wanted to do since
i was a kid
i've never said this i've never told
this to anyone i'm about to say it on
this
show like all i've ever wanted to do is
be a comedian
i had eddie murphy's head shot in my
locker in the seventh grade
people had [ __ ] chachi and [ __ ] when
you opened my locker up it was eddie
murphy in a black leather jacket or the
adidas with the
you know smile on that eddie murphy
smile in my locker
i've wanted to be a comedian forever be
involved in comedy do comedy and
just like you and everyone else in here
we have
thrown our lives into this art form that
might
this might be gone i mean it might be
called this might be it
so at this point be nice to people yeah
and do
but do whatever the [ __ ] you want
because it doesn't matter in the end
it we talked about all these jobs like
these athletes these
these photographers anything in the arts
is that that involves people
dj you think of it whatever involves a
crowd is in jeopardy
at this point it's in limbo right and
there's going to be a lot of shift to
different things
and you're either going to thrive or
you're going to [ __ ] fall
but in the meantime you want that
[ __ ]
tattoo on your face get it get it get it
get two of them
get it get it [ __ ] that job interview
you think you want
need so bad get the tattoo on your you
know what i'm saying like
whatever you want as long as you're not
hurting anyone
then do whatever the [ __ ] you want
because life
doesn't give uh it ain't 20 20 that
doesn't give a [ __ ] about anything yeah
it is
life that doesn't give a [ __ ] about what
you want to do
yes true well there's no like you know
this put a pause on on what we love
doing the most
is stand up i mean i love doing podcasts
so
[ __ ] much uh but i missed the thing
that fueled kind of my nighttime fire
you know
it's the heroine it doesn't matter
whether it's your your
your wonderful series or a podcast or
whatever all that [ __ ] you know
it's it we're recording ahead now to do
other [ __ ] so it could be weeks before
you listen to this
or hear it and there's
there's no and but there's no live
audience there's nothing like
the yeah there's nothing good or bad
yeah
there's nothing like the immediate
feedback of stand-up comedy
even if you're i'm in the number one
blockbuster film of the year
when's it come out it's gonna be another
eight months you know what i mean that's
that that doesn't feel the [ __ ] i
know i was thinking about that when i
was having a uh
i was having one of those reflective
sessions i talked to rogan for a while
you know
the other day because he was talking
about you know saying goodbye and
all that stuff before he takes off and i
was like man it's so crazy that
not too long ago we were in a [ __ ]
arena filled with people
an arena i mean just months ago it was
crazy and he was he was like man isn't
that [ __ ] up we were supposed to go to
vancouver for 4 20 and
all these plans that had kind of gone by
the wayside that i had had so
much excitement for all i want to say
to myself and to the public is when it
does come back
we can't [ __ ] wait to come like i
can't
wait to go back like i am so excited for
when it comes back because i still have
hope it's going to be the best
i'm going to have the most fun on tour
that i've ever had in my [ __ ] life
because
that's exactly god you realize how
fleeting it is
i'm going to have so much more fun man i
cannot [ __ ] wait like
like something i started that i i kind
of got away from because i it just
didn't work
but i was doing this fridays with a fan
where i just had fans email from
whatever city and it was like
i'm going to pick somebody we're going
to kick it during the day because i was
doing weekends
i changed because i was doing small
theater so it would that was harder
because it was on a tuesday or
what people have to work you know but i
was doing fridays with a fan
making people take off work and kicking
it with them it was so much fun
and i know when when the tour comes back
regardless uh
of when i'm i want to do that again just
because it was just so
like it just made me feel how important
it was
in terms of what i was doing socially it
was like having fun with the fan also
enjoying a city
and then going to have a good show at
night i mean it was just like the
trifecta it was so
[ __ ] oh it made me soak up what i was
doing a little bit more
and i want to get back to that so i hope
when we do get back it'll be that kind
of vibe of like
yeah just eat it up dude you know i
never sat in my hotel room i never
i never ever sat you don't know guys
that sid and they just jerk off and
watch tv
until the show never dude i always was
out
always out trying to find some [ __ ] do
some [ __ ] cause
you've cause it's your life you forget
you're like bro this is
it's not another week in another city
this is your life you're still your life
yeah it's my job
this is my life i can't just do this and
then go well i just can't wait to get
home it's like
that's not it you have to live while
you're living because otherwise look at
what happens
they take it gets taken away from you
i'm saying like i never thought i would
say anything like this to my kids but
hey
if you don't want to go to college [ __ ]
college college
just be happy because right now nobody's
going to [ __ ] college
right i was literally on a zoom call
this morning
with a bunch of other [ __ ] parents
for kindergarteners
my stepson's gonna be a senior i can't
imagine you know i don't blame him one
bit that he feels like
school's over yeah it feels like that
because you don't have to go to that
[ __ ] building and guess what i would
too if i was 17.
i'd be like [ __ ] this yeah [ __ ] that
this isn't what i was signed up for it's
what we have to do now so
for a lot of people like us like oh
you're not missing anything it's like
yeah well with hindsight
i don't really give a [ __ ] about
graduating i mean i ca
yes yes i would i put all the nerves and
anxiety in the pomp and circumstance of
literally walking down the aisle and
graduating from high school
no no no but to a kid that has been
busting their ass there's valedictorians
out there that aren't going to be able
to get up and speak and you know
so many things going on zoom speeches
zoom yeah that's what i was on today a
[ __ ] zoom call so
you know i don't know how the [ __ ] i'm
gonna this this country's about to get a
whole lot dumber with these parents us
parents we we
we were told we had to do this [ __ ] once
i got i don't even know how to do the
math
you changed math bro i can't this
country's about to be it's already dumb
it's about to get
real [ __ ] you know put them to work
even
even the kindergartner put them to work
it might be a shift like that
i'm gonna bring all the kids in here and
be like let's go yeah let's let them
teach each other and [ __ ]
find the smartest kid in all and i'll
just let just talk to him for a couple
hours
because i like i don't know how i would
deal with that i have a friend could you
imagine right now though being
16 and told you just got to stay in the
house with your parents
every [ __ ] day and take class on a
computer you'd be like [ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that yeah that'd be too
hard man
i way too hard yeah i don't get it i
don't know
i don't know man i don't know what the
future of that even means especially
because we live in a city so i'm saying
who knows what the future of anything is
do whatever the [ __ ] you want that's it
have some fun have fun
that's it like if this doesn't help you
with stress and anxiety then you haven't
been that stressed out
this is a this is telling you right now
that
hey all that [ __ ] that you thought
mattered it doesn't no
it can be taken away we we always think
about
you know don't want to take tomorrow for
granted it could be taken away usually
when we all
mean that i i mean at least for me
especially i'm talking about death
yeah it can be t it's good that's what i
usually
you don't think like yeah but uh you're
gonna have to sit in your [ __ ] house
while there's a goddamn virus out there
like wait what
yeah you're like is it gonna kill me no
no not right now i can watch tv the air
the air won't be deadly
water all the food i need [ __ ]
[Music]
but i can't do stand-up no what what
can't go to work
i mean that that that's that's my only
hope is this is it
is time to do what the [ __ ] you want out
there and go for it whatever it is
yeah and and and uh face tattoo it up
get a face tattoo get that motorcycle
yeah
don't wear the helmet ah [ __ ] that out
it's increasing the death rate [ __ ] it
seat belt's gone
[ __ ] the rules at this point why the
[ __ ]
not yeah i think have some fun i think
have some fun try your best that's all
i'm i always say that people i'm like oh
try your best i don't know [ __ ] it you
know what i mean what are you gonna do
this thing is this thing is going to be
what it is for a while and then we'll
come out on the other side and we'll
look back and go god damn that was
[ __ ] wild but who knows what the
other side looks like so
in the meantime i'm just going to keep
plugging away having fun
and then uh maybe we'll make it out and
be okay on the other side
maybe not and if not whatever whatever
it was all right
all right i it's been a great you know
what it's been all right
if you'd have told 16 year old me that
yeah i would have had
any of the experiences i've been
fortunate enough to have
in this crazy business yeah i would have
been
jumping through the room same wait what
i get to go do joe rogan's podcast
yeah and it's gonna be one of the
biggest shows in the world what
oh you know i get to have [ __ ] tommy
lee on my 60
what yeah it's wild get the it would
you'd be jumping
up 100 [ __ ] down yeah 100 i think
about that stuff
and they're like yeah it's gonna go
great for you you're gonna be doing so
good oh
yes but wait what but then there's this
virus like wait what are you talking
about
i get aids or something no no the whole
world's gonna get it what
what do you think global age it's slow
away it's lung aids and
things are gonna just get shut down
you're not gonna be able to do anything
shit's gonna suck for a while all right
okay
but i would have taken it i would have
taken the hit yeah that's what i'm
saying
yeah fine i would take the hit our
water's not poison our air is not
pouring like this [ __ ] sucks we all
there ain't a person out there it's like
i'm thriving maybe there is i do want to
meet the [ __ ]
there are some people that are you know
that are doing yeah there's a
billionaire there's a billionaire's
reason like i've made more money i want
to meet the power walker out there it's
like what 2020 is about a year
you know what i mean like i want to
that's what we should do a podcast
called twenty twenty
years
my fourth yacht is doing very well thank
you
i diversified my portfolio more than i
ever have you know that a lot of people
making big money
big big money yeah but uh god bless the
people that are out of work that are
trying to [ __ ] make it work and and
and trying to get back to you
because that means tough it gets [ __ ]
scary for everybody
even if you have money even if you have
money at some point
most people didn't have money a lot of
people born into and you remember when
twenty dollars meant a lot
oh yeah i remember when twenty dollars
was a weekend yeah forty was scary to
get out of the atm yes
remember that when you're like yes 40
bucks what the [ __ ] am i gonna do this
is two weeks
this is half the month right here two
weeks out of the [ __ ] atm
yeah that was scary i remember taking
out 40 bucks being like
like we got a budget oh my knees behind
the other 20.
don't use it yeah don't use it that was
like the first time we went to vegas we
were sober
i had a hundred dollars and i was like i
can't lose all this i can't lose this
hundred dollars
in vegas and i spent it within the first
like six hours and i was panicking i was
like
[ __ ] lost on my [ __ ] money i knew
my mind i knew when our neighborhood was
not great in baltimore when i could go
to the provident bank it was called
provident bank
and a minimum withdrawal was five bucks
i swear to god you could get a five out
of five five bucks
just give me five bro you could in that
baltimore neighborhood and people got it
yeah they needed it
i got it i would get i'm over there
slipping a five out just to go to
mcdonald's and [ __ ] you know like ah
just five just five just five can you
give me four is four good
it's only 3.99 i did just hit me with
four and i walk
five bucks before the debit card and all
the bang bang
bang you know like all that [ __ ] five
bucks and now cash is out no one's gonna
use cash everyone's touching it
coins are gone yeah but you know what
i'm okay we're going to get the [ __ ] out
of here with the coin thing they got to
go
no we don't need them i think they got
to go i'm ready for i'm ready for a
castle society
all right let me ask you this question i
haven't asked anybody yeah let's say
hypothetically
live entertainment you could still
podcast whatever stand up stand-up's
gone though
forever they come out and they say no
it's illegal banned it's never gonna
happen again
what are you gonna do what would you do
we're too old to go for but sports are
going i'm still doing all my other [ __ ]
you could do pocket yeah all that [ __ ]
what would you do though to fill the
void of stand up
i'd probably i'd probably
pack well first of all i'd keep
podcasting and i try to do the tv show
if i could still act but i would uh
i'd honestly focus more of my time on
creating different
[ __ ] which is kind of what we're trying
to do right now like i would just keep
trying to create different new [ __ ] yeah
um i would secretly my secret yeah yeah
uh i i want to make music so bad
more than anything but i don't really
want to give it to anybody i don't want
to put it out anymore i'm not trying are
you a singer
you talking about no producing yeah i
want to just make music we're going to
rap
no i wanna make music with people okay i
don't know i don't i don't care what it
is i just wanna i would love to be
i'd love to be a producer i would love
to produce with people
give my influence give my opinions i can
play a couple instruments here and there
what do you play
name it what do you play i play drums
when i play drums when i was young
really that was like my foray into music
yeah i learned on drums when i was a kid
and then
my mother took him away two yeah yeah
right school slipped a little bit she
was like you're not gonna get to bang on
[ __ ] drums
if you can't get a c you know i was like
how fine what you know it ain't gonna
matter in twenty two
candy hits the pandy panty hits this
ain't gonna matter mama
yeah music music i would love to learn
and i would love to learn
i would love to learn more of the
digital space of music because i'm
fascinated with it i'm
fascinated by by digital i think it's
crazy i know it's not people's favorite
you know people still love
you know physically making music with
instruments but there's something about
digital that's so
that's mind-bending to me i think it's
the future of of everything i think at
some point we'll just only use
instruments are [ __ ] are tough it's
hard to lug around all that big ass drum
set
i know it's the sound is better i know
it feels better for those who play but
i'm fascinated by digital music there's
something about it that all that sound
is captured and created right
in a thing and i can just i can
manipulate it a billion different ways
you can do more with it than an
instrument actually can at some point
right i mean it's because it's because
it's
it's generated all the sounds it could
possibly generate but
nothing sounds better than that but i
just think there's something about
new i've always had i've always had akin
to music i've always had like an
obsession with ingesting it and wanting
to make it but i just don't
if i had the time that's what i would do
i would spend all my nights making music
duncan trussell tried to get me into
some [ __ ] he wanted me to order one of
those [ __ ] uh
oh what are they called it's like a
board with all those plugs and he's like
i watch shaq loves that [ __ ] it is wild
yeah it's wild
i can't i don't know why i can't know
the name but i'm gonna i'm stupid but
duncan and i were messing with that for
hours i was fascinated with how cool it
was it was just so
intricate and also simple he's like you
can make it whatever you want there
doesn't have to have
any kind of rhythm or movement to it
he's like it is what you want it to be
and i don't know i like that i like that
a lot i was that i think is my little
secret that one day maybe i'll get into
if i can ever
get the balls to like go buy the [ __ ]
and just sit down and do it for hours
and hours
so i'm just gonna keep like i was
telling you before this creating shows
different shows lead with comedy you're
already making mostly yeah but you know
we've got some other really cool [ __ ]
coming up but uh and then just help kids
yeah i wanna help i wanna help people
that you know this show definitely does
which i never
even set out to do that i just i love
comedians and i've always loved
talking to someone who can tell you
the worst [ __ ] story and still make
you [ __ ] laugh so hard about
something in there right where you're
like who is this person that can [ __ ] so
i've been fortunate with this show that
i've gotten to fall in love with
comedians all over again and just
re-appreciate how [ __ ] not only
[ __ ] up they are but how they can take
that [ __ ] up
and make it and make it funny yeah you
know yeah no that
no it is it is a it is a blessing for
sure to like uh
there's no i say that all the time to my
old lady i would say because we're sick
something's wrong with us we see things
really weird and it's not like i'm
saying we're not special i just know
that when i speak to other people
the way we see things is just like it's
an inch off center it's like a little
bit like
because i say stuff and someone will go
oh yeah i didn't know and it's in my
mind i'm like that's very normal i can't
believe you don't think about it like
that me too for the longest time like
why
why is that yeah well it's because we
just have a little we just view it a
little bit differently
if you if you have comedy in your blood
there's something about it
that was my whole family was that way
certainly none of them were stand-up
comedians but
they would make light of this tragedy
and always drop a joke in there
always switch a gear always something
and you're like
i'd rather run with that pack of people
than the the
woe is me uh you know pity party people
over here like [ __ ] that we same
problems we're just
doing a lot differently totally dealing
with it yeah
well that's i think it comes from uh
comedy
has almost uniquely uh in its history
always come from not not just tragedy
but from
uh hardship right like most most of the
funniest
people you know came from tough places
i'm not saying you need to come from a
tough world to be funny i've said that
before but
it helps i guess i don't know i think
something about it helps because it
shapes the way you view the world if
everything is hunky-dory
kind of like you know what do you have
to your perspective is not that
harsh because you didn't really you have
to live the hardships right right it's
like if you never rode a bus
you wouldn't know how to write a joke
about riding the bus that's right but
even if you've never rode a bus and
never rode a bus if i've written a joke
funny enough about that bus you'll
relate you'll get it yeah even if you
never rode the bus that's right so
something about that there's something
about the
things that bind us i'm watching a good
show by the way called connected on
netflix you should watch
okay it's [ __ ] brilliant for people
that are listening if you if you were
looking for a new documentary series
it's all about how we are
inherently completely interconnected and
as cliche as it sounds
we are the show breaks it down to the
simple the dust in the saharan desert
is affecting the way you eat and the way
things grow and the it's just something
so
minut always translates into a million
other things it's
fascinating dude how it affects the
amazon and how it rains there
and and the patterns of which affect the
way food grows that gets to you the way
the ocean eats the way it blocks
it's just like it's it's it's it's
at the most fascinating connected
connectedness
connected and dave watch dave on hulu
yeah if you if you got if you have hulu
i love you dude watch it i love you plug
everything again yeah no watch dave on
hulu uh
it's we're coming out with another
season next year but in the meantime
watch bad friends
me and bobby lee's podcast on youtube
and everywhere you could listen to it
and
uh whiskey ginger uh which is my solo
show with a with uh with a guest
sick dog was on it you're gonna come
back and do it now that we're in the new
studio yeah yeah yeah and hang out
and uh other than that dude you know
keep supporting this community because
this is what keeps us
going right now because we can't be out
there seeing you so this helps so
appreciate you appreciate it appreciate
appreciate you appreciate you brother
uh as always ryan sickler on all social
media ryan sickler.com
we'll talk to you all next week
[Music]
you